Donna is in Fort Lauderdale hey Donna
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi how
are you better than I deserve what's up
well going into baby step three in about
two weeks
good thank you and just I want to lose
momentum do you have any tips how long
should this next step take six months to
a year max what's your household income
about 38 to 40 thousand okay how much
dad have you paid off so far it fell see
how long it take you to do that here in
two months okay
and so your income your take on page
three thousand dollars a month so three
to six months of expenses is going to be
somewhere in the range of ten thousand
dollars eight thousand dollars so took
you about a year to do the other one
probably take you about a year to do
this one okay yeah getting kind of
concerned about my age and retirement
and condo needing repairs and hold are
old are you 52 you know the only way to
reasonably accessible to retirement and
you have an emergency you know what
you'll use your use your retirement
that's true that's why we put it as baby
step you know the emergency fund is
before retirement because people use it
for the wrong stuff you'll cash out your
401 K and take the penalties I had a guy
earlier in the hour that did that and
he's paying big up rs bill right now
just exactly because of that and so I'll
be able to catch up at W oh yeah you'll
catch up you're only 52 I feel that's
your chicken just bring up something
like I'm gonna marry a genius and he
kind of second either well I don't know
that Marian a genius is this closest way
to wealth anyway I think the closest way
to wealth might be in your mirror so
yeah you know I'm 55 and you know so I
mean we're going to make it kiddo those
of us right
now here's the thing what I would say is
this the average household income which
often times as two incomes granted is
52,000 so at 38 you're on the lower end
of the spectrum even as a single and so
one thing I would challenge you to do is
to say okay a 52
I want to be doing when I'm 60 that
makes 80,000 a year and what are the
steps to get there instead of looking at
this as you're already old and you're
just going to kind of slide into home
plate here let's go ahead and say the
number one decade of income-earning
of Americans is their 50s okay I thought
it was 40 yeah it's 50s and the reason
is is that you finally get enough wisdom
and life experience and it all starts to
come together within a career typically
okay and so more people make more money
during the 50s than they do age of 50 to
60 than they do any other decade they
slow down in their 60s typically and in
their 40s are just quite not hit the top
yet you know and so that so but I you
know what we call it in your case is um
you're probably working really really
really hard for that 38,000 you got that
right what do you do working in the
trade show business we do boat shows in
South Florida cool sounds fun it's hard
work though trade shows tough man almost
call it country you just walking your
butt off on that concrete yeah
I spent a lot of time doing that too
doing speaking because we're walking
back and forth in these venues and
everything but the yeah so I'm going to
ask myself what in the 50s which if you
start over or if you just start a steep
incline with your career meaning you
start making a lot more we call that an
encore career kind of a second career
it's like you come back out and take
another bow on stage you know kind of
thing that's an encore and so that's
what I want you to do I want you to
start thinking fresh again instead of
thinking and quit telling yourself
you're old cuz you're really not okay
I mean really statistically or not you
could live the 90 which means you're
middle-aged and so just just
mathematically you're not old now you
know walking those concrete floors make
you feel old some days I got that okay
but maybe we need to start adjusting
that and I'm not saying you quit today
or something silly like that no but I am
saying you're going to be making
thirty-eight thousand eight years from
now still
walking those concrete floors unless you
start aiming at something else right I
agree with that and so I want you to
start thinking about that side of the
equation and my point of all of that is
mathematically that's as much an answer
to your retirement fears as trying to
jump as trying to leapfrog over and
start doing retirement without your
emergency fund in place
so put your emergency fund in place over
the next 12 months and then start doing
some goal-setting and reading and
thinking about what do I want to be
doing maybe you want to be owning a
trade show company where someone else
walks the floors by the time you're that
age I don't know but you know what is it
you want to do and what is it that's
brought you to this point I'm going to
send you a copy of a book we sell a lot
of on that subject it's called start and
I want you to treat your emotions in
your mind like you're 19 or 20 years old
you're just coming out of high school or
college and you're just starting and you
say what could I do if I could do what
would I do if I could do anything
because you need to ask yourself the
exactly the same question what could I
what would I do if I could do anything
because you know what you can do
anything all you gotta do is just aside
just like that just do it just decide
today I'm going to not do that this is
America we don't live in Russia you can
just decide and so begin deciding to do
something and be something different
over the next ten years and double or
triple your income I really do think you
can just you won't though if you think
you're old
hey you guys Rachael Cruz here hope you
are enjoying the Dave Ramsey show and
did you know that I have my very own
YouTube channel yes that's right kind of
better
I'm kidding I'm kidding so subscribe and
there's lots of videos about life and
money so while you're at it if you want
to check out a video then you can check
out how to do a monthly budget it's one
of the best videos out there
you